what was your very first memory
of um what uh caught your eye or
drew you in about photography for
yourself
i love how photography
captures the the
it's a document of the truth but then
it's also
artistic it gives lots of room for
creative expression but then it's also
like
like this this video that we're gonna do
or this the photograph i did of you
is it is a document of who you are today
absolutely
but at the same time it's kind of like
this
visual like little treat you know it's
almost like
you know i'm trying to make it look
pleasing to the eye or at least
interesting to the eye
or the mind so so i dress it up a little
bit in my little
ways without without doing too much i'm
not retouching and making your
you know your blemishes you know
disappear or anything like that but
but there's a way of lighting it there's
a way of putting a backdrop behind you
and things like that to make it
look a little less softening the edges
yeah just just making it
easier to easier to look at easier on
the eye
yeah with something so i love that
combination
um of different things sorry to
interrupt but one thing
what was your first memory of
photography that drew you into it for
yourself you didn't hear me i don't
think
your very first memory like when you're
i don't know how old you are when you
well i started out shooting concerts
when i was in
uh like 15. that's cool what kind of
concerts yeah so i would wait offer
tickets for every single show that came
through chicago i like that one movie
kind of
with the journalist and the uh yeah kind
of like that i saw that movie reminded
me of me
what was it i forget the name of it um
but i uh
i would wait out for front row seats for
every single show that came through
chicago
from from the stones to the to the
smallest bands that would come through
and i'd go
i went to probably thousands or easily
hundreds of concerts between the ages of
15 and maybe 18 or 19.
oh that's and and i would take i would
take photos of all these bands
and you still have those photos probably
yeah i guess i don't i don't i
tend to like not look back i just
somebody asked me the other day like
where are those photos i don't know i'm
not going to dig them up oh my gosh
but yeah they're they were great they
were great it was really fun ladies
if you bust those my youth that'd be
cool to see your uh career
or your your adventure in photography as
an
artist it's cool to see your own work
like in the states
it's important as an artist or as a
photographer to shoot things you love
right back in high school i was really
into music so shooting concerts
made perfect sense for me back then but
now i'm older and
uh you know i'm more interested in
psychology and
and how we how we deal with life and how
we end up where we are and uh
so that led me to this project uh can
you just tell me when to go
all right uh i'm sorry name is daniella
yes danielle danielle
uh danielle where'd you grow up um i
grew up in a little town
um north of l.a a little bit like
topanga canyon oh japan cool
my family was a second family to
homestead there
a lot of people who know me know that
they know my grandma
rose wiley my uncles tapanga is a very
how would you describe it it's a well
today
uh today it's very different i know that
back in the day it was known for
um it's like where the hippies went
after hayden h but ashbury because
over in san francisco was too expensive
to paying it was a lot
cheaper and news by the beach and it was
warmer right so so your childhood was
looked like what um it was nice my mom's
a hippie
my grandma was a little bit more
conservative but we
have a lot of the old remnants of like
cowboy days in topanga on our little
ranch
and growing up was
interesting because everybody went to
school with was either
um is either an artist of some sort
dancer
poet musicians uh
photographers so and so forth so it's
been fun to run around with a group of
people who are very artistic
in that sense you had siblings no
siblings
um my mom just had me they my parents
divorced when i was
two or three and then they um
yeah sorry i drew a blank how would you
describe your childhood
it was bitters it was um
bittersweet i would say definitely um
it was my mom was an alcoholic and my
grandparents were
um they took care of me a lot of times
when my mom would go to work
and um yeah my mom
would drink uh when she'd get home and
sometimes she'd get a little like
violent or whatever and crazy and um
my dad wasn't around he failed for
same similar reasons and um
yeah so i could say them it was
um a lot of my girlfriend's parents kind
of always took care of me
and um in different ways like um
i don't know i was really close with my
girlfriends growing up
and then um actually you can't think
um but my grandparents are very sweet
and loving and warm and so is my mom my
mom has
a different side of her and i don't give
her credit for it probably enough
but shh they taught me probably a lot of
things that i know i know how to sew
i know how to ride a bike tie my shoe
um write read the dictionary look up
different words in the source all kinds
of different stuff because my
grandparents
and um
uh yeah and then when i was 13
i went to boarding school um and i
wanted to get away because
growing up i was like a chubbier kid and
so
i got made fun of a little bit and i'm
not gonna like
i probably downplayed it a little bit
but it was um difficult
in elementary school to like be that kid
and so i always like thought that when i
grew up my life could be a little bit
different than it is right now but
that's like for later
um but yeah once i got out of
um elementary school in topanga my uncle
george
is my dad's brother i stayed in contact
like a little bit
throughout my childhood mind you with my
dad and he passed away when i was 14.
but when i first went to go
see if it would be a good fit to go to
different schools either in california
or outside of the state
um for boarding school i went to
it's out in arizona off the 17 highway
and that school was really cool
i've got to ride horses and go on
caravans and like
learned a lot of cool stuff and that
like served me well
and then i got kicked out um in ninth
grade
and i was ever kicked out for what two
years i
started smoking pot and i was bringing
it onto campus
and this kid in my class who was a day
student
and he would bring it back in like these
science tubes
i can't believe i said the school's name
almost one time anyways i'll take it
down
um yeah he they were like huge and
they're just giant like
buds and so i would go and smoke and my
girlfriends
there's five of us um
and they were all uh kids of the
teachers who worked there so and i was
the only one who didn't
have any association with the school so
when i started smoking
their parents knew because they could
smell it on them
but they'd watch out for me and they'd
be like danielle come on
and i started with cigarettes camel and
filters and then i
um then i brought in the pot afterwards
and then they all started smoking pot
with me
and then it was we were burnt
but it was fun um once i got left there
i went to nebraska and
during the period of time when i was at
um out in arizona at school
my mom was trying to find a place to
move to um
i'm doing this gonna ask backwards but
um
she wanted we needed to find a place to
live we couldn't stay on my
grandmother's ranch anymore
because the house that my mom had built
and it wasn't all the way done like you
know what's banging
is this little bit all these little
houses are like built into the hillside
versus the hillside being taken out and
flattened
yes so my mom did just that and i had a
little loft
and it got didn't have a permit no
so the building inspectors were like
coming and
checking on the property because my
grandma's having like
some debacle with her brother
who owns like um just 10 acres so like
i think three acres on the other side
was like his and
it's whatever he was trying to make a
big stink about it
and they showed up and they said we had
to pay us this
or the house gets torn down and then
during that time as well my dad was
calling my mom out there from arizona
which is even weirder and he wanted to
come out
um wanted her to come out because he
wasn't doing so good
and like he's hanging out with a bunch
of weirdo tweakers and like
doing speed and like if anybody knows
that [ __ ]
it's like back in the day it was hell
fun i'm sure
80s was cool cocaine then tweak or speed
came out everybody's like just going
well
a lot of [ __ ] problems came from that
generation doing just that
they just never stopped forgot
everything
behind left everything behind including
their kids anyways
um do you think that you're the
childhood that you had
a very alternative childhood because of
i just i
used to like pray and beg you to where
you are today
yeah um no absolutely not
because i have been given so many
opportunities to do well and i'm not
going to sit here and
like [ __ ] anybody and like justify
why i'm out running muck like
there's no reason other than part of it
i'm lazy
yeah and um two i lack the discipline
and i could
have that self-discipline i choose not
to and it's really lame
um
because i know that
but anyways um
um i always just wanted like a normal uh
thank you
[ __ ] it's like so heavy um i don't know
why
um i just wanted to be normal
like it was really hard elementary
school was really
hard and i learned to be really cool
from it
i learned how to be really cool from it
i feel like it helped me
but you think the body shaming that you
experienced as a child kind of
i mean i still don't want to go out for
you to be accepted and cool
no no i think that going
having gone through that
taught me to be more compassionate in
others and i can relate
to people on all on all on all
the whole scale all skills i feel like
there has been a few people i've met in
my life that and i love people i love to
talk to them i love hearing their
stories this is
i do the same thing you do but without a
camera um after
school i lived in nebraska
at that point my father had passed away
my uncle george and i have like this
crazy very simple relationship um
we um can talk about a lot of things
he's a very quiet well-mannered man and
he's a businessman he's got a lot of
stuff going on
and he's always trying to look out for
me the best of his ability
and i probably have kind of put up some
walls around it and didn't realize it
then um but uh he's kind of been my
mentor
so when i left school he was not happy
because he helped he was paid for you
know he put
um money that was left for me on it but
still um wow
i was kind of upset but i think i did it
because my mom wanted me to come home
and i'm like a total like sucker for my
mom
i like i love her to judge and she's
taught me about loyalty and loyalty is
like
a really big deal and it's weird that
people don't really appreciate
those kinds of like values and morale
these days
yes most of us a lot a lot people do
but like um sometimes not so much on
like uh
that kind of stuff especially down here
yeah no
world is not a forgiving place so today
you're living where
um i live in chico today but um
i moved up there after i lived in
um ran away in salt lake city which
is where like i went uh went to after
leaving nebraska because my mom and i i
got on probation out there
my mom and i left after i got off and
like um
we stopped there for because it's second
cousin's wedding and i knew this chick
and we stayed like my mom put me in
school up there so i started talking to
some chick about running away and like
within two weeks of being out there i
ran away
five minutes down the street from my
house i was at
my mom had court that day too because
she had dui
and i [ __ ] took off she was pissed
i was like i'm gonna go be my own
independent person i'm gonna be an adult
because i'm 15.
smoking swagweed and out in salt lake
city
so strange and i moved in with like a
heroin addict
and she was a really bad heroin
her husband was a truck driver and he
had a really nice house like
nice things cool stuff whatever spoiled
her to death
she had her own house because she had
all her own stuff
and um her own apartment and we all were
all
partying there all the time i don't
think she really ever went home except
for maybe once a week
and then um we would get high
and i was dating a 24 year old at the
time um
because my girlfriend gemma gemma
introduced me to
sam and it's weird
to look back and see what i've done and
be like
any older do you try to be with some
younger chick in front of me i would pop
him in his face like
no and um yeah sorry to anybody who's
like you know
down for that like i'm just saying it's
not
cool no little girl needs to be in that
position
but he was a lame he'd get we would get
high we'd smoke hella dope
and then two months later three months
later i called home
wanted to come home then i moved up to
paradise
california and that's where i've been
since i was
15. well now there's not much of a town
left so
but i'm up in chico i went back from my
mom
i came out there from san diego which is
where i got sober at
what are you doing on skid row today um
well um i'm going to try to hustle up
some money
and then um no i have some uh i have
drugs to sell basically so i'm just
going to go do that
whatever i need to get home north
because i have an eviction coming up on
monday
then i don't get there before mon if
monday all my stuff gets thrown away or
in
it'll get thrown away mine are you using
currently
yeah i'm not gonna use forever though
and everybody says that and that's
i hope everybody means it is i mean
though i hope everybody means it when
they say they're gonna quit
because everybody says it but they don't
mean it yeah
i'm serious what are you using um
it's kind of like a really good question
i like to i like this little pot
i like to drink lots of late
and um i s
i'll i i'll smoke crap with my boyfriend
once in a while and then i shoot heroin
and um that's like uh
i don't even know why stuff it just all
began with like um
that feel-good sensation you know it's
not feel good everybody wants to chase
it
it's amazing like um i admire athletes
because
they go the extra mile and do it all
naturally like
you can like discipline is much more
of a finer um like
a better and finer taste to do and have
than it is to go and
shoot okay um than it is to go and shoot
heroin like it's better to be like
do what you're doing than shooting hair
obviously
but it's a serious thing so um
that's pretty much what i have to say i
guess how long you've been using
so that was 15. oh really
no no i only picked a pair when the last
i don't even know why i used to be like
i used to love cocaine
and then i went to speed the harder
drugs you've been using for how long
so since i was 15. i used to use my
mouth with my mom
[Music]
yeah that was like um not she would not
ever slam
my mom is old school she hates this [ __ ]
she would kill me probably she
watched this video and knew it was on
internet
but she hates it
she's not like junkies at all
so i just um found it romantic
like i kind of always knew like when i
was little like i would look
i would like i romanticized it like i
don't know
how and why i like um can say these
things
now but it's true like listening to like
i don't know i guess it was nirvana and
stuff like that
but even before that like drugs in my
brain were like
cool police no and i didn't really have
a lot of
like gangster or like outside or any not
gangster even just like
some city stuff like those
in depending on it's like sheltered so
like the influence was
really not comparable to anything except
for i put that
in my own head which is weird i think
but your family was doing
you know drugs are in your family so
yeah huh the drugs are in your family
they're i'm actually a black sheep of my
family like my mom
like my uncle a couple of my uncles were
um did their thing but never with drugs
and then back in the day and but now
everybody's my pretty family's pretty
successful
which is even stranger because but you
and your mom using it
yeah at a young age yeah well yeah that
opens the doors for all kinds of other
stuff
absolutely and people say pot doesn't
doesn't open the gateway
it does because it teaches you how to
socialize and under those circumstances
you learn how to navigate the whole
little
um drug ring or whatever like oh i gotta
talk this language and i
uh today i gotta wear my hat backwards
because they don't you know i'm not a
cop
do you have kids i i do
i do i have a daughter and i had her
when i was 20.
and um i was doing really good
um i didn't when i found out i was
pregnant i didn't use anymore i wasn't
using
black at the time um my
baby daddy was in prison and
then he got out when i was seven months
he left when i was
zero months or like one day or one week
i should
i don't know um yeah
and then when he got out
uh we tried to make it work and it
didn't work he's got
some mental stuff going on my mom was
always in the middle of my relationships
and then yeah my daughter is
11 now and she's doing really well she
lives with the family the family talks
my grandparents and my uncle and my
my uh cousins and stuff but um
my name hasn't really been mentioned so
i don't know
we'll wait
do you see where do you see your life
going now
hopefully somewhere like where the
thoughts in my head and the ideas and
the dreams and things i think about
because i know i think about cool [ __ ]
um
i hope that i'm able to produce that and
stop talking about it and be about it
honestly
because like as much as it is cool to
like go get high and stuff because like
i'm not going to do unless i'm
enjoying it at this point um
i just hope i'm able to fulfill some of
the things i think
that's it that's all i want they're
getting clean is tough
no staying clean staying clean
i was sober for four and a half years
and then went out
so um
we'll see hopefully i'm able to do some
cool [ __ ] i love art i do a lot of art
stuff
i paint i write i i don't do
anything if you want to try something
new like i'll just
figure it out you know and love fashion
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the more somebody tries to tell you that
you're not crazy
if your intuition says that you know
that there's really something going on
and you can say for 100
that you know within yourself your
judgment is usually almost
right then you should probably stick to
what the
you felt the first time because whatever
it is it's
probably happening so don't let people
[ __ ] with your head dude
and be aware of it when it's happening
and if you like to
play along then that's you know
everybody else's business but
that [ __ ] ain't cool you know if you
don't really believe in something don't
go along with it you know or if
something bad's happening say something
that's a big thing a lot of the world
like wants to just be a people pleaser
and
say it's okay to like get along with
things
all right danielle thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for having
me sorry i was a little crazy in the
beginning yeah
i got two stone before that all right
thank you thank you so much
you